[موسيقى]
تعرضت تركيا منذ مطلع الشهر الجاري لسلسله
زلازل مدمره عقبتها الاف الهزات
الارتداديه واعتبرت من اقوى الزلازل التي
حصلت في الاناضول منذ الفي عام ففي السادس
من شهر فبراير الجاري ضرب زلزال جنوب شرقي
تركيا وشمالي سوريا بقوه سبع درجات فاصله
ثمانيه واعقبه اخر بعد ساعات بقوه سبع
درجات فاصله خمسه على مقياس ريختر ووصل
مداهم التدميري حتى حلب السوريه ما اودى
بحياه عشرات الالاف من الاشخاص في البلدين
بالاضافه الى دمار مادي ضخم تبعتهما اكثر
من سته الاف هزه ارتداديه وفي العشرين من
شهر فبراير الجاري ضرب زلزالان بقوه 6
درجات فاصل اربعه وخمسه درجات فاصل ثمانيه
على مقياس ريختار محافظه هاتاي جنوبيه
تركيه وامتدا الى السوري وشعر بهما سكان
لبنان وفلسطين وتثير هذه الزلازل
المتتاليه التساؤلات عن هذه الظاهره فهل
هي ما يعرف بتجمع الزلازل الذي يحدث فيه
اكثر من هزه ارضيه رئيسيه في منطقه ضيقه
خلال مده زمنيه محدوده بايام او اشهر